let's try to calculate ten point one
minus three point nine three and I
encourage you to pause this video and
try it on your own first and then we can
think about whether we did it the same
way so let's just rewrite it aligning
the decimal and the different place
values so ten point one minus the three
is in the ones place I'll put it right
under the zero three point nine three
now let's just try to calculate this now
before we subtract we want all the
numbers on top to be larger than the
numbers on the bottom and we don't even
have a number here we could stick a zero
here let me do that in a different color
here we could stick a 0 here 3.0 10.1 is
the same thing as ten point one zero but
we still face an issue here zero is less
than three one is less than nine zero is
less than three so we're gonna have to
do a little bit of regrouping so let's
do that regrouping so we could take at
an away one ten away and then one ten is
the same thing as ten ones so I could
write a 10 in the ones place and I could
take one of those ones away so I'm gonna
have nine ones and give that one to the
tenths place well one is ten tenths ten
tenths plus one tenth is going to be
eleven tenths now I could take one of
those tenths away and give it to the
hundredths place one tenth is ten
hundredths ten hundredths and now I have
a higher digit in the numerator or at
least as equal in the numerator as I
have in the denominator so 10 minus 3 is
7 10 minus 9 is 1 I have the decimal 9
minus 3 is 6 and then I have nothing
over here
so 10 point one minus three point nine
three six point six point one seven